[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je
aliot des choses se passent sur d'un
coprévenu je ne sais pas les raconter
j'avais prévu que sarkozy juppé ce matin
kg puis après koh lanta en direct au sol
pis que valve se prendre une taule
pareil dans cette révolution commence
comme ça la révolution citoyenne c'est
pareil que ça commence par un moment où
l'ancien système la [ __ ] est en lui-même
je suis pas semblant d'avoir une
doctrine révolutionnaire d'accord
rassemblant alors des fois je fais
semblant de parler d'autre chose elle se
tient de la violence en moi mais oui
mais vous la trouvez les allez perdre à
t'as vu ça t'as vu c'est dégueulasse et
ça allait on s'en va tu aurais encore eu
deux trois mois
j'entre
pagani thing j'animais
[Musique]
j'aurais pu former lisez ton plate
augusto mélenchon donc là et les causes
sont croisées avec hamon mais maintenant
on s'occupe du suivant dans la liste le
suivant de liste c'est monsieur fillon
c'est plus compliqué si on le rate afssa
change tout la république inachevé temps
quand le peuple mais pas fou le rat dans
son pays en tout et pour tout elop le
groupe représente pas une secte mais le
peuple français d'accord à partir de ce
second volet voulu bien dans la tête ça
va vous donner du de la respiration et
sinon on aura bien travaillé et puis
voilà